two folks were so full podcast with
Felipe Esparza and was Lila Torian yeah
men all the way from Riverside and hear
their own podcast
yeah man how's that going good good good
got a solo in the truck on Thursday you
know 3000 SolarWorld row well you gotta
do a solo woman you don't have no guests
you mean I know I started on I tried
doing about myself but then always like
paused Twitter laughs a response that's
why we messed up my auditions bro
thermalization you told me to face the
camera you know but you read read to me
so I'm reading to the lady but then I
look at the camera for reaction hey if
it so used to being alone done yeah man
so I blew another audition so I'm going
back to acting classes bro
yep yeah cheaper one this time well you
better put this dude right here they
didn't get it out John Huck you can get
either he goes I thought you were gonna
get it damn you guys were neck and neck
now we're neck and neck bro cuz usually
like they know they wanna are they know
what they want they know what they want
as far as the person the captain
director they say okay fat guys between
the 30 and 40 and 50 years old so she's
looking for a third 40 38 year old guy
curly hair looks crazy so I came in
there I think they got the crazy or he's
balling out yeah yeah he's pound it down
with the remember we're now Don Johnson
showed up with a stepson ha ha ha that
crazy fool here this [ __ ] for the road -
oh really that did yeah I mean ok
that fool was ready for the roll bro he
came in like with his pants tucked in
looking the part
damn I wish you're probably like when
you're going for a reading like I went
for a reading in Spanish for a
newscaster right so I just go regular
you know about my other chapters really
audition reading everyone they're
good-looking and then some people came
to a stop bro
this camera don't fake microphone
reportando hisses okay to see the valet
kkkkk why ever ever okay but the lapel
and I de dama he was the whole acting
paid the acting book a funny man you
were seeing that he would just joke
dress up look it was [ __ ] I told you
I took an acting class before right good
Josie at house yeah that's right I'll
get you a small pot this lady yelled at
me dog is it you're not act and you're
fat feels like a Latina chick and she
said I just came from an audition look
how I'm dressed
- a dress like for what disappear we got
a police officer [ __ ] well as acting
class who talked to your mom
actor circle beater dog that's a meanly
gosh she was mean dog hey but uh you
know that's why I figured that the more
the the I go the more the more in acting
class cars the more the guys gonna teach
you and put you down oh well that's what
I'll just he's got to put you down if he
coming back
oh yeah we're gonna say you're awesome
don't ever come back that's what I wrote
our fresh daughter and his burning book
he kept saying that the first order you
know he kind of shy you know he don't
get the best chick or any chick right so
he he was like spilling like quitting an
acting class but then the teacher
started make starting him started
putting him really with hot chicks and
him you make our scene gotta get that in
there for pay $100 for just to make ours
cheese dogs damn you got no game you can
do it for free
yeah dude but the most I learned was
from Joe Diaz Oh dog look I bet you're
like laughs now you're some brownie you
become the characters brother and myself
all areas boys on prowl in the shower
how's this guy shower house this guy
drives hair you know I'm saying this guy
brushes teeth where's my glasses this
character has glass but I get it
Stanislavski over here you know I mean
the method is [ __ ] but I mean other than
that out no [ __ ] pool you know just to
[ __ ] you go on you mean
well now I'm at like I would go like
they tell me like I'll go to the acting
class and I'm reading my lines he goes
watch it what you get what's the
characters point of view what do you
want out of this scene what is it go
main goal you know what's just want and
I'm like [ __ ] all that bro you tell me
and I'll do it
why was I figure it out well if you know
you're an acting coach
if this were your lines who would you
want and tell me please I don't know
what I don't know what I am NOT doing
what's so hard for the acting code to
tell me what it might want and so you're
paying them all there's two different
ones no no no you want me to keep coming
back to this shitty acting class don't
pay a lot of money bro
ah dude it'll be I'll try to trick you
in both they need a brother
they need a father a mom in the same
damn how would I ask like a flower were
two acting classes I've been acting
since I was six done you're like goddamn
a child actor we didn't renew yeah I saw
your big acting robro ah now that that's
taken show you run into the casino
doesn't CSI damn I love acting class
people take understand like or another
one I would see to I'll go to acting
class and there were these two teachers
and they all had like a degree in acting
a master's in acting Fine Arts others
and that from Yale from Yale but they're
teaching me you know
now you say all that money but they know
everything the history of acting
everything man and like man and I'm like
really man you guys just shared a
burrito right now because we have enough
money to buy one I'm gonna tell me how
to act
the method is split in the burrito let
me say well I'm gonna tell you how to
get a free burrito next to you what so
talk with that try to speak Spanish in
the gap will feel sorry for you already
instead of sitting at Corazon you
teaching them some acts because one
thing man I've always learned like I'm
not the greatest-looking guy in the
world
the guy was the best team I have the
best top teeth now before work you were
bad bro nice crew I was afraid did it I
was a little butter apple and in the top
I'm gonna pull my tooth out
I can bite it with the side one dog do
before these teeth my teeth were bad bro
I used to floss with microphones three
microphone wires well it was bad bro you
know some people spit water out my
output like five water hose into a
sprinkler does your my teeth bro I think
yeah the like semen white and
oh not even dog what do you hope family
have good teeth but my mom does dog my
dad is my dad seats are [ __ ] up that's
I got a little ass Mountain big-ass
teeth my mom his big mouth and big teeth
my dad has [ __ ] up teeth and little
mouth oh so everything out my mom's
teeth oh oh should buy a where people
have everything broke five so to
proofread even in slender the whole
family's good look about I know my name
six-foot-two slender bro beautiful wide
nice can never had a pimple will you do
for a living I'm a cop
well you look at myself a whole family's
[ __ ] up a fat fool a buck people my
family bro it is my family is like the
Periodic Chart bro I was went backwards
there forward we started standing up
they might have [ __ ] up its back in
reversing the evolution trial as a
little chart evolution chart we got here
from the knowledge of word of Steve over
there was a periodic shows the one with
elements right Breaking Bad
do not turn boron sorry watching
Breaking Bad again man you did yeah I've
only watched a couple of bits of that
second part like somebody tell me a
Philippe we live in the house and 35
minutes okay
turn the wok on open sort of Breaking
Bad at 22 minutes some people I should
get ready in 25 minutes but I start
doing other stuff like cleaning around
the house
pick up stuff around the house before
they leave not my I late I said I said
down broad I waste take off my shoes I
wait another 40 minutes I used to be
organized I'm a liar bro I don't even
know how I did it better than as a kid
as a kid I remember Wakeman wake me up
to go to school then I sit in a bed like
this then I go back to sleep
you were dream that you got up and got
ready but you're still sleeping no but I
thought in my whole life bro all right
man
what's your show coming up we have off
for last week um I'm just uh Wednesday
night all I do have a show this Saturday
I'll be in Whittier with fly with your
dad at stage nah hang on okay damn will
be your [ __ ] uncle anyways man
tonight August 18 I'll be at the
Milwaukee Wisconsin at Potawatomi
Casino in the Northern Lights Theatre
two shows one night get tickets at
Ticketmaster or at the box office in
person I'll be live about 300 Torres and
some dude named Adam Murray anybody next
week August 24 through 27 I'm back at
the BRIT improv get your ticket tickets
are going fast man people from Santa Ana
just taking all the tickets man February
7 to the 10th I'll be in Orlando Florida
at Orlando improv we're back it's been a
year since I've been there it's been a
long time I think the last time I was
there there was that I'm the shooting at
that club over there in Orlando yeah I
had a sold-out show the next day broke
80 people showed up no the bad week in
Orlando but I was a crazy as a girl
crying mom a girl from America's Got
Talent
she was shot by a crazy fan bro dad I
said that's what you think happened
right the night before like the guy was
like the merch booth right worst boo
remember that she walked up to her and
just shot her point-blank it was crazy
that I killed at the moment in Orlando
then the day after that there was the
shooting at the club and right at post
but then after that this alligator
killed a girl
no yeah in the Disney Senator yeah the
little boy right yeah yeah and the daddy
[ __ ] dude dad we can afford it so am
I like it right now he's so many shoes
right now boots yeah man so what if I
got here September September the 24th or
24th Houston Texas I'll be at the improv
September 15 and 16 three shows on
Saturday at the San Jose improv in San
Jose where we filmed the HBO special
last year shutout give the shout out bro
yeah man to the no namer podcast guys
for giving dougie points to people who
like the trailer for Philippos HBO
special on HBO's YouTube channel made us
laugh Ramos family business on Instagram
he's a dedicated viewer of our podcast
on YouTube hell yeah
the other regular YouTube Watchers and
commenter sick boy nine one five one
three Phillippi double e 32 our Samoan
friend USO 209 eks Oh also kuku con la
Moody and a bunch of more regulars
I think our Irish homely Glen Karlin
also watches us on his big screen at
home
hell yeah top of our morning to you mate
alright go for this oh you got that too
late oh yeah oh we got that oh yeah we
got that now review you oughta breasts
we don't notice that moving faster well
I don't move your [ __ ] loss dude dude
you're talking about [ __ ] on your
always dude [ __ ] dude I blessed [ __ ]
at home dog that I [ __ ] needs it's
over there I respond you get a little
Oxnard tonight too right I am [ __ ] I
guess I gotta go about [ __ ] by
Sherdog [ __ ] but anyways we'll get you a
rose for less but that's it Dawg I'm
over here [ __ ] tripping I wanted to
get the deal [ __ ] this anyways so what's
up fool
chili dog you gonna do it you're doing a
show with you to the show as I'm that
guy McDaniel right that was last
Wednesday yeah my dad and Jane Murphy
Jane Murphy old-school mag the letter
showed with her Etta at the saddle ranch
oh did connect in a daze you know it's
crazy the first one of the first time we
were doing that um Lovitz Club she was
there one night yeah sure enough right
yeah yeah yeah she's cool so yeah man it
was [ __ ] cool Rico Mambo show a
ten-foot man so that one last comment
stallion 2010 time has cologne there
seven years doesn't stop them seven
years bro and I remember at me pretend I
remember from 2003 to the other Ted
Tywin slow bro for me Charlie
time with a struggle time was bad every
minute counts
I had a I had like four years where
nothing good happened to me it's like
nothing good like I felt like I think it
a good a good show like a good shoulder
help me out for the next three months
you get something to get a good show oh
yeah then I help you all with bills for
the next three months four months and
then you like but damn and nothing
happened but all my shows were in our
layout to struggle I was doing like a
pity dollar show here in Pomona a $75 in
a Wolverton with
Gilbert Esquivel I [ __ ] out a redeemer
Ellen Show for a hundred here man I
firstly I would do like four shows a
night just to come up with $200 and then
like I would like 75 75 16 somebody will
call me up and Philippe another show for
30 all right listen I'll do it I'm gonna
go first and get the [ __ ] out of there
because I get the money to make the
other shows expect the other shows do it
never told you that I went on uh on a
binge but like uh like a bad binge bro
with um let's play it off on Friday and
no started up on front Wednesday or
Thursday and stopped Saturday when I
when I had to do a lowrider show damn I
don't know where it started off but I
did a lot of shows on Sunday maybe I did
a show on no sleep and I was partying
the night before you know doing out cold
you know loser I got out and I was not
sleeping right and I'm I met it was like
I said I fly I got a show man hundred
bucks bro just picked me up so I was
given output they're gonna give me 200
but not gonna get a 100 because I meant
they were in no way able to do this it
was bad to like it was like I was dirty
first of all was dirty as hell
rock stars I'm so dirty like my
underwear fell during my socks I was
sliding out of my socks inside my shoes
it's like Motley Crue's dog you know
what you get your feet are moist and you
haven't taken them off so I was slippin
in my shoes bro like I found I wasn't
walking I'll stop but my shoes my people
slide in the shoe that's how bad it was
and I went to a witness to the gas
station right there and by sealer
converse Montebello like the killer side
of calm or Commerce and Montebello meet
by the factories and I say man I got a
sobered up man and a chauffer some kids
right now Dan so I went to I went to the
gas station like a crackhead bro just
get a big bump in their broad they
didn't care that it worries I somebody's
at work please
so I just lit a fat ten in the pipe ride
your car
like little the bathroom for like a
loser and I threw my underwear in the
trashcan because I was dirty too
now I'm working with pads no underwear
crackhead broke and I took flight take
me to that show and I'm trying to sober
up trying to stay clean you know but and
my eyes are red flag goes up then like
we're in sin in a city of Downey it's a
bunch of I am and a bunch of kids and
their parents and they're there for
comedy it's a fundraiser for the cutter
hey I guess and I don't know how I did
it man but you did it I pulled that one
hour out of my ass and made everybody
laugh they had no idea that I was on I
was inebriated I didn't shake no hands
after that show I ran to go do another
show I remember man there was a guy the
front and his daughter had a broken arm
she's a four year old girl right three
year old for your girl's a broken arm
and she laughing at my joke with her arm
going like this and then I looked and
then I looked at the data to her cost
and then I broke characters it similar
to me huh but you [ __ ] that break
your [ __ ] arm [ __ ] die ah
hey Oscar relax already done come on me
huh would it work why do you break you
out cuz you [ __ ] drop milk or what
yes sir leave me everything that a
parent would do to kill their kid for
something and they were all laughing
what happening that you spilled milk and
your dad knew exactly how much you
spilled on the front cover on your
spilled 46s of milk anyway so class so I
don't know what happened after that
a special I ended up at UM some
somebody's birthday party from the
Comedy Store the guy that does a podcast
the mushroom podcast Duncan Trussell
oh I never talked of Tressel's house
with your Z and fly are you and some
other fools so I'm over there like bro
my face I'm like I even know how like
I'm afraid to look at myself in the
mirror damn right I have no underwear on
I'm chef shaking bride own trash get
free ball I was walking bro like I have
known each apps close I don't want to
bend them cuz every time I bend them in
between my cry
she's ready no hurry like Redfoo like
like somebody's slightly with a knife
right there bros bad [ __ ] rah rah ha
food sound I smell like uh like somebody
throws a Gucci
so that I put in my pocket as you let it
rest there for 360 days rest
just cuz I was gonna eat it I was bad
bro so I still care do the show and
after that show in Downey I stood to
walk alone in Montebello to get pink
Obama still inside but you know I gotta
pick up my $75 there for hosting so I
got there i total guy listen man I'm not
really a host so I want you to host half
of the show I'll do the rest
so by the time I got there other
computers went up whoo
so let's do another 35 there so I met up
with a couple of Mongols there bro and
um I was kind of like you know like a bi
never spoken to them before about
anything I was gonna make a drug deal
for 20 bucks let's just at $20 like I
say listen bro I would even give you a
ride my motorcycle 20 bug damn nothing
bro nothing slow when I showed up to
Duncan Trussell house all [ __ ] up and
there's kind of like the party was
ending all the party is over can I have
this in so I got a big bottle of vodka
and cranberry juice bro all danny
bonaduce style and I took it with me
that is utterly done the curb so I don't
know what happened the next day where we
like slept or not least I right here Kim
came in like a soldier drove me in her
little ass Toyota all the way to Fresno
to do the one-nighter okay an angel like
an angel and I'm passed out of her car
like [ __ ] Robert Downey jr. and in
less than zero she don't know if I was
gonna die in a car seat I kept like God
I kept doing that and [ __ ] like my body
was shaking nobody could kick it all
that [ __ ] my body was like locking up
inside a car bro was like doing this cuz
you know the drugs and not laying down
you know when you're like party you're
sitting like this for a long time so
that stiffens up your body to do the
lawyer on up now you're all sore from
the top midsection boo I don't know how
I did it man and show up to a lowrider
show and the guy that's the air precise
god bless the guy man remembers Gilbert
I think Gilbert the main guy from
lowrider and I had to perform right
before II for T and some other rappers
okay
and I'm in my own green room with a
bunch of the rappers I might earn up to
a week full-time still awake I get to
the I get to the show with five hours of
sleep I opened up with Matt we have a
little uh police' I was already show wow
maybe with a lot of fine ass cars here
lowriders bicycles the only car kind of
don't like here is the black and white
one
you know everybody started laugh-in bro
at least all right there man the one
with lots of room in the backseat
you know cuz seats you know barbed wire
fence you know that such detail in the
LAPD Kota Fresno PD and pulled it off
Lisa right here drove me back to LA I
went to sleep and she still went back to
work at the Laugh Factory I at the Laugh
Factory in Hollywood for to be a
waitress that night still made it huh
and now the night Dave Chappelle can for
hours yeah she worried about me all
night and then you know of course as
soon as I sobered up I said a little
prayer and took off again in a bad light
I want you when you live in the Attic
life you feel like you get there three
days rest and you feel energized like
but not in a just you go look for a job
or change your life another commander
nothing positive the apology to another
bender and I and that was my life from
2003 to 2009 after yeah man I'm lucky to
be here bro
damn GG you got the hey I promise she'll
every night ma'am whether you believe in
God or not I say I think somebody man
who's always watching over me hey man
thank you for another breath somehow
some ways out having me here a man now
I'm gonna let you down again don't worry
about that you receive it yourself if I
get out of this I am gonna change and
let me tell you man I try but I changed
for one hour that's it it'll be all slow
change when you get different when you
will become an adult you have to lift
yourself up
there's no more help you know one forty
thirty forty five forty nine fifty five
Purdue nobody wants to help you no more
you're lost cause I remember a father
Greg Boyle from homeboy industry he was
here he picked me up when I was 21 after
I drank was [ __ ] seven zimas little
seven um noxeema Cisco's Cisco's oh did
I drink didn't it [ __ ] me over
no Doheny cuz he uh were you live in the
hood sometime the hood comes up with her
own drinks like Cisco and Old English in
a slow cup [ __ ] City walk left in the
neighborhood like you're in out Bahamas
bro that's how I feel that's how I
managed to not go crazy like all the
home in the neighborhood bro mindset
every time I drag something right that's
good mmm
yeah bro we're in the Bahamas right now
I was you're happy enough I know I want
to be somebody bit somewhere nice you
know like some people get loaded and
they want to torture somebody for that
dog let me break my own windows even
make this guy some good quesadillas
looking Bourdain over here done I love
now bro like Eman like I try to find
things to like not go back to one doing
drugs or drugs everywhere I see a long
till on pinky uh-hmm
bring over here a bag dipper yeah man
and they're not a lot of a sum of shout
out to Trinidad men mix Trinidad I don't
know your name is from Facebook this
fool just fell off the wagon he calls me
up and he [ __ ] video chat i chat with
him one time and now he's over there all
la corte again and [ __ ] with wife
laughter man I'm putting all your
business out there my Facebook kid
anyways yeah so he's also doing it bro
I'm a Trinidad if you're listening man
I'm one-day-at-a-time broke Tijuana
wasn't built in a day bro just looked at
we were so full we have a guest today
bro a very very special guest I'm
introducing my number Amaro know I have
a long intro but how I found out about
him first of all
I when I want you to III start off with
something I would end up with something
else
like like you know like remember when
albums used to come out like real albums
I'd say wrap it up and they will lie in
your notes you know like a star to Lisa
the lyrics lyrics result I'm pleased to
give awards for liner notes she said you
know because I was in a word I'd
actually found out more information
about the person in fan club fan club or
Holly Led Zeppelin come out with its
album you know what what were they
thinking about
so everything would be in the liner
notes right so during the more liner
notes you buy a CD you download it you
know [ __ ] about somebody nobody bothers
to read the information iTunes who reads
that I don't hear the song yes I hear
the song so on YouTube you get to watch
the song but in the comments you know
you know the people start talking about
he's so good like like if you want to
like feel good about yourself go listen
to an oldies on YouTube an oldie song or
or break your wood you know something
like that
okay okay Rosalina and then leave it to
the notes let's read the comments he-man
you get so you get freaky I get
goosebumps sometimes bro the nostalgia
nostalgia from the people like oh man
this song reminded me of 1989 man it was
a prom and whatever it was a problem
Roosevelt and I mean I will dance with
my Luca at the time you know and then we
get shattered that vision of cheese I
mean man but it was a good time you know
the time before that but then you want
to find out more about this idiot who
got hula broke his heart can you follow
him
you check on his page so he was into the
kid investigation you know somehow ended
up in a rap battle and then he didn't
see us
then I ended up at UM at da and some
guys to reference actual gang cut out
reading alike beat like the gangs had
rappers that were just wrapping gangster
like The Avenues can represent he's got
a bottle flat and in the harbor area you
know and then brown feeds bellies
then I run into MC poncho right here
right that's how you got to yeah good
night see MC poncho could use our sons
of anarchy right you know he will OS
turn the bike and I sell it at Tuesday
wait a minute I think it had before
somewhere on Instagram and it should
mean I assume on YouTube okay but then
like I thought it like I wanted so then
I got more into it I started digging
into all his interviews I know his
patties now I know where he can sit on
Memorial Day but I want to bite him I
know where restaurant he said my team
event I know I mean and I found out his
wife right here I don't find a whole lot
a bit together I found out you know he's
our lunch already she say this guy's
actually he's not actually gangster told
her like like after shooting people that
that she had a real life he knows the
Xolos on the side I do on the side and
anyway so I found out um they do you
like I found out give [ __ ] bro like like
stuff like I like that you Capri she
like when we had um remember when we had
on kid frost here right and we had our
citric and then we had a Baby Bash so
and now we had some some other fool that
we had here saying intimate details
intimate detail so I want to know why
I'm asleep I'll show you know why when
did they start well our kids right here
who is from a harbor harbor city harbor
area I don't know this was bet nobody
here this guy did an article what I
thought it was fascinating bro like how
big the universe is how big social media
is he was doing an interview and he said
that somebody you know he put up our a
hip-hop cassette in other people along
the hustling styled like MC Hammer would
have cassette like in the 90s or
mixtapes issue yeah and so his mixtape
ended up in Japan so and 5,000 copies
were sold and 60 bucks each he didn't
receive a dime jack micron is Auburn
no no the
he's like that he's like the underground
rapper in Japan they flew his ass over
to perform I like that
so man any country ought to at my album
somewhere man Indonesia Guam holler at
your boy cuz I need work
and you go to him right yeah I'm see
I've seen no matter I'm like at that
like I said at that legacy show that
Hurley shown early a combination show
which was that that uh for that teenager
exhibition that they had their
collaboration and I've seen you another
little red shows you know always like
gang of people around them trying to end
up here like here look at a house party
headed house and it'll trip you one
right he has a house party with your
birthday and I'm there all your other
friends were there and other rappers
whether the local rappers and I'm the
guy rest in peace I don't know his name
brother [ __ ] abroad was there I just got
the weight TT X devotee X and he stood a
rapping you know MC Pancho you know
shout out everybody was taken to a
rapping dude
Gilbert Esparza was there Hubert and
sparsely the singer from the cannonballs
Oh Greg Greg his greatest greatest
parcel was there I didn't know him
because he didn't sponsor and I'm his
chick his friend is friends with Mattie
Murray know that she come the Lexia or
Victoria Vincentian intention when
Cynthia his friends was Greg as far as I
that's who I met Greg and um anyway so
Greg was at a party right it I laughed
because everybody rapid writing great to
the rap so he's up to going happy
birthday if he Pancho
whatever man I died he's a crooner this
was came in hardcore rap Ebro you're a
raps birthday wraps then MC Pancho gives
the microphone to Greg as far as open
look for the Midnighters and then like
he don't know what to do bro he just
starts going go go go go
urinating it was like email lae agencies
left with the mold on then you head up
hot here a house party where I'm a bunch
of troll over there everybody's showing
their tattoo work like it was like it
was like a barbecue trigger to a to cook
now what happens at bachelor parties bro
what happened brother oh man eh Emily
2:30 having dinner I started to the to
our show and our Convention Center right
here oh my god yeah mess or MC Pancho
he's a guy that I know appreciate music
fine food fine art and no yeah and I
feel mom eating at you you ate at that
steak house place the the one with the
trailer and downtown LA what's it called
a Pacific dining car oh my god vizor one
time research I was invited there after
a show with these so-called average
Latino politicians the real politician
bro when I check in with a split it I
thought there with a pace for my food
bro yeah I had a steak huh I was loaded
too I was loaded I called Lisa be steak
right now are you doing sleeping in full
from color here yeah it was um that
place was in a movie traffic training
training my bad I would've made a big
deal with it Denzel Washington will rob
the other cup oh okay yeah laryngitis
Brooke one of the best steaks I ever had
the last pic ever had really yeah man
that steak comes out juicy was a little
bit of brown gravy I'm not a lot of
gravy it's enough it's enough to say
okay this player here and two two fried
eggs over hashbrowns the fattest toast
ever had with extra butter of course I
forgot how much you're worth bro but if
I would have known when I when I went
sounds heavenly does I knew I shouldn't
be there bro because I will I stop first
of all you've been partying for like a
day you don't want to see aprons bro I
saw a tablecloth I saw everything real
need
I said wow man I shouldn't be here but
yeah good it was good hell yeah
so we're so fool belong an intro ever
good introduction none there's a lot and
um you know y'all hear you hear the cat
you know grew up in the 80s you know you
know very fortunate you know him and I
were from the same the three of us right
here we grew up in a time in LA when
they were beautiful bro you know those
gang violence there was cracks up a
little hip-hop now the genial hip-hop
the beginning of breakdancing you too
public too right yes yes I did
yeah man I went to a video haha I went
to a video where there's a guy - dude
some real [ __ ] pop lockers girl and
there's some some Boeing Fuller show
them along here their food is a co few
artists dog he's like as helpful he's
dressed like a go full artist really I
think we all kind of pop-locking bro
like walking on air and [ __ ] legit legit
hell yeah I did and then of course many
people start doing it but back then but
you can really pop lock and and start
doing your move like that but pop lucky
but you might do a Crips I get jump
happen a lot bro yeah especially a
better than Beach so that would you pick
your real that's what the real popular
crews were bro in 1987 to see they never
were like this yeah man come with no
push I remember I saw this [ __ ] at
movie called skateboarding okay I don't
know why but it was like a gang of
skateboarders and now though some guy
pop locking in and [ __ ] your betters and
this bully a skateboard will not you
April a break Dutch is dead homie Chris
and then skateboarding was in you know
Tony Hawk on all these let them know let
him know times are changing so were so
fool we have energy Pancho now house
welcome bro thank you so much it's a
true honor to be here and Felipe
honestly I'm uh I'm really touched I
didn't know you were following me and
you knew my whole here I thought I was
gonna have to do some talking here here
ever was that that is a true honor thank
you thank you so much have a bit of fun
I've been like I don't know how where I
first saw your page but it must have
been it with a puddle a rapper that we
had here or at a party but I do know
Greg
and put if you live it will you live I
live in San Pedro run from the harbour
area yes so we have a friend who lived
in Wilmington that's Christian and he
does comedy shows in that area
Gilbert Esquivel oh I've done shows with
your words out very dear friend of mine
yes that's what I first saw you
Gilbert asked about and he's chilling
bro his arm is like that and he's like
yes yes I can see it yes I know higher
the arm goes humorous Cabral was a good
friend of my man like he was the first
guy I told him I told I have a gambling
problem you know I have a meet up it
once I quit drinking and drugs bro I
pick up another additional baseball
cards boy I would wait you more money on
baseball cards I'd better crack get up
ridiculous oh then now man top top clear
baby Bowman Bowman oh and um let's talk
about our would you grew up at San Pedro
in Europe in the 80s I employees I'm 47
I was born in 70 and so the 80s I
started off young ladies were my era and
I survived the 90s which were you know
pretty crazy I mean you you were there
bro everywhere everywhere so I survived
that all I started off rapping at the
age of 18 17 18 I start off as a DJ
actually from DJ I got into wrapping the
whole thing's like a fairytale I did
underground I did 30 mixtapes called the
harbor area sounds and that was educated
that was dedicated to a little girl who
was handicapped so the money off that
first volume all the money went to her I
was sound him out of a duffle bag I was
a duffle bag boy and they opened up an
account for her so when CDs came in I
had no way of making a CD I don't even
know what a CD was so I hung it up right
there I retired at 1994 I think at 24
years old
stronger rap that was it I was done 2006
I lost my mother so I went through
morning from 2006 to 2008 during that
time trauma D time my wife talked me
into doing the CD which I did not want
to do it was a 20 year anniversary of
those mixtapes so I ended up doing a CD
while I was fortunate Japan heard about
it and a DJ had came out back in 88
bought my cassettes at a swap meet and
was like this guy's
alive we thought he was either dead or
legit just get them out here get him out
here we'll do a press conference so I
Rolling Stone magazine all the major
magazines we have they have in Japan and
I went out there and I did an interview
and it was like a fairy tale I mean I
would be talking to you right now if it
wasn't for that CD if it wasn't for
Charlie - pushing me to do that CD and
things happen for a reason if I want to
lost my mother I want to have my
testimonies and my stories to tell you
know the things I went through and
social media played a big role can make
you or break you and it's done both for
me what kind of toll did you go through
I don't know what I see that on your arm
on your Instagram that once your dad
passed away you and your mom became
really tight well I lost my dad a
wonderful heaven rose yeah yeah she was
shorter let it's very short but powerful
my dad was diagnosed with ALS which is
Lou Gehrig's disease during that time it
was rare very rare they didn't even know
what to diagnose it as so I lost my dad
when I was yeah nine nine months before
that we lost my brother doing overdose
of heroin on Mother's Day so that
brought me and my mother just I mean it
was just us two and she pretty much
dedicated and devoted her whole life to
me
Shama Rita is living proof you know what
I mean she was with me to the end so she
taught me everything my mom was a
gangster she had a very very filthy
mouth but you couldn't put nothing on
her you know I would call her and tell
her mom I'm ditching today so if they
call you you know I mean if I get
arrested or whatever it may be and you
know stuff like that and she was like
okay well thank you for telling me but
you took the fun out of it you're not
supposed to tell me these things
you know so she was very very streetwise
and her way of bringing me up was a lot
different you know I didn't think we
were poor but she would tell me stuff
like well we don't like that kind of
food but it was her way of saying I
can't afford it so I grew up not liking
a lot of things before I even tried it
did not and that's the truth the other
children when I got with chairman Issa I
tell her no we don't like that and it
carried on to my older dad I just sort
of had yeah we don't like that kind of
stuff you know but it was it was her way
of saying you know or she would do stuff
weird like this pretend we're camping
and we're in the middle of nowhere and
this is all we got to eat so we would
open up cans of denison or whiny those
made a little and stuff like that and I
grew up on that and I appreciated it you
know
now that's why you see me going crazy in
those restaurants and I like the fact
that I work for it I could do that and I
could go in there and I could buy $100
say that's how much the Pacific dining
car steaks are
that's the Cowboys state you know yeah I
was there last night and I liked the
fact that they welcomed me in there and
they don't stereotype because I have
gotten stereotyped a lot because of my
tattoos my long pinky nails the jewelry
etc but I mean I have nothing to hide I
have no skeletons in the closet and I'm
legit l7 square guy that's funny man you
meet your mother - both giggle you have
to help anything easy lie to you or just
say no cover no I know no I was it
wasn't happening there was no liar
nothing but that would tell me like I
would ask for something Norma got that
for you
Cassadine you I feel so many things were
bad for me bro
I said beer so I'm your father arm he
was born raised in the same area you
were born my father was yes I mean he
originated from Colton area came down at
an early age he was a professional boxer
and then oh the name says so so so chic
Araiza and he's as well somebody he was
the highest decorated our area for the
Silver Star he received a Silver Star in
Korea he took four bullets and two
Purple Hearts so I mean he was a highly
decorated Army veteran second and an
infantry you know and longshoreman so
that's how I got in down there because
when he passed away I was eligible to
get his book which we pass on to to a
family member a son or a daughter and
take over supporting our family so
that's what I did how does that work
though for people don't know the
longshoremen that um so you could like
you could give your job to your son or
your cousin and you it's actually I
immediate it's a son or a daughter with
the you know the whole if the mother
doesn't remarry or the father so now
your sole supporter of that family
you're taking over a lot of you know
that's the whole purpose of this and my
mom was we were perfect I mean we're a
perfect example of that my mom never
remarried
they had that I passed away when I was
eight
when I turned 18 I was eligible because
she never remarried so nobody was taking
care of us you know I mean just what we
got by WIPP Social Security and it was
time for me to step up and get that job
so I started working a longshoreman
which is a good job right with my
dentist hello yeah I'd good area fit oh
yes I mean like I said that job saved my
life you know I mean I could be in
prison right now I could be dead but I
started working right out of high school
at 18 not knowing anything I mean I
graduated I made a promise that I
graduate cap and gown but I mean I have
one of the highest blue-collar paid
union jobs out there and I'm proud to be
a longshoreman I got 31 years down there
awesome man thank you um my wife and I
we went we went to last year we went to
well watching in the San Pedro area and
we noticed that there were a lot of
boats on the dock like not coming in so
it like a big big strike right there's a
big stretch in the dock we never went on
strike what they did probably during
that time was locked us out there's any
lottery guys out there in contract yeah
a lot of people at that time did not
know what a longshoreman was yeah until
that hit the media I mean people as far
as Mississippi knew what a longshoreman
was because what you have on from head
to toe
I probably unload it out of a container
so it was during the time that the
medium really bashed does made us look
bad that we were greedy yeah if we
wanted more money and we wanted this but
it had nothing to do with that it was
the automation that was coming in and it
was going to cut a lot of manpower jobs
there so that's what that was about
and we didn't go on strike one day we
showed up to work the gates were locked
we couldn't get in so they locked us out
and the president had to step in during
that time on a longshoreman doesn't have
regular I would like a regular person he
comes in when the boats come in so you
get a call no that would be a linesman
those are the ones that tie in the ships
and they're longshore as well you have a
day side you have a nice side and then
you have a hoot shift which is like
three o'clock on so you have three
different shifts on that so you choose
what you want but you have an
opportunity to work a second shift which
I've never have and I don't support that
because we make enough money on one
shift and I mean I'm happy with that
it's giving me a fortunate life and give
somebody else a chance I mean what the
first time I went to the lot of the
orders of the San Pedro was I went to
the
I went to the shipyards brought up a
little kid field trip
okay a Long Beach shipyard bro when you
started looking around and I'm thinking
well he's got some job I don't want to
do here big ass crane big ass cranes a
big ol boss follow me bro
it's another world right there right I
don't we have a friend a friend of ours
remember that little fool a to put the
comedy show cell Oh Samson Braun oh yeah
he sport
he's in charge watch the Port Authority
in San Pedro
right right right cuz I don't remember
had a government job he did on that he
said guy that watches over make sure no
no contraband comes in note your head of
trailer come in with full of ice ice I
had a trailer come in full of
Ecuadorians I was unloading oh man
that's a story they were stolen well as
they were stowaways so back in the days
we used to load bananas you know if you
tell the longshore lingo I did bananas
you hear grandfather's talk about that
well I had the opportunity to do that so
we were unloading a little did I know
there were stowaways in that in that
hatch of the ship that we were doing and
as we got closer and closer and closer
they were in that little pile right
there so all of a sudden they just came
out they came out they knocked the pile
down I hollered they hollered we're all
screaming and they're running around and
they know we're going nowhere to go they
caught him they had a little jail on the
ship and they put him in there and you
know we all gave him actually our
clothes off our backs and gave him some
money they led us to the little jail
cell and they were back to Ecuador you
know wow man a container that's a long
trip
this is that no food or water or what I
mean they had stuff because they were in
the ship okay you know in the ship it
was in the hatch of the ship but then it
was another time I didn't have a car and
I remember I slept during my lunch hour
and I was slapped right by a container I
was sleeping and there was some genie
toes from China coming out and they came
out of a container they were in the
container that I was actually unloading
and that one hit the news and everything
and I think was right there because they
have ships at hat because the [ __ ] that
we see on the on the road with the with
the diesels those those are kook water
containers container ships are they on
top of barges or shipper or both well
they're on they're on top of the ship
they're on deck and below deck so you
those ships can earn enormous you yes
yes and they're bigger I mean
they're huge now I I could even tell you
how many are on there because I haven't
worked on the ship in a while I unload
the containers from with the machine oh
it's just crane rated it's called a top
pounder so I pick up those containers I
put them on a trucker or I take them off
or I stack them 6i some line you know
that's that's what I do and the chanita
were inside those consider in one of
those containers I remember it was my
lunch break I was parked right there
next to him I knocked out I woke up for
a little bit I looked and they were
sneaking out yeah that was 1988 I mean
we got that good hard job work real hard
yeah sort of all I got seniority I put
in my work because there's a there's a
job right there like a crane operator
it's a lottery right people go there
every day to show up for work and
depending on the numbers they pick no
those would be casuals that are
non-union onion and they wait and they
get what's left over from all the union
members from our dispatch hall so then
it goes to theirs
and then they get a job and right now
the works pretty bit much picking up
from what I hear they're getting four
days a week but then there were some
times they're getting one day a month or
depending on how you know the peak is if
it's a busy or or not
right now it's busy so so good things
job opportunity for everybody
how hard is it for someone who have no
body in the Union I don't know anybody a
longshoreman to get into a longshoreman
okay I'm glad you asked that because at
one time yes it was who you know
remember you what tell you put up all
they were hi everyone right watch
everything okay Wow I'm sure they're
looking for Logan gills
yeah that was nice of you to do that no
we put it out there so did yamaneika
she's used Union as well she's local 63
so we put that out there for the world
to see and a lot of people got
discouraged at always who you know can I
use your name I'm like yeah right lots
of other stuff like this is see how far
that you show me oh yeah yeah no yeah so
exactly you know I mean there was there
was people we put it out there but a lot
of people got discouraged in like
knowledge rigged and it's a net well
what they did was they drew if you were
to meld in a white postcard I mean all
you had to do was just mail in that
postcard some people got picked in the
first hundred they didn't know anybody
with the white postcard then we were
issued as union members what is called
an interest card what you were to think
it'd be rigged and those are the ones
are going to
well the fella I gave mine to he was
25,000 and people with the regular one
were in the first hundred so that
gentleman that I gave mine to probably
won't get picked for another maybe 10 to
15 years Wow so that goes to show you
it's not rigged it's really luck it's
not no more who you know because there's
too many lawsuits so many license on
that so you know if they cleaned it up
the whole nepotism thing yeah yeah you
gotta know somebody doc you gotta know
someone everywhere the whole welder room
well the number father was doing it
whole like who the welder he where's he
welded our kind of stuff I spoke to my
mom she said that my dad would want
together with well Dean um the Panama
Canal pieces of it but when he send it
to him oh yeah that's what all comes the
pieces of Sam Hill working hard in the
70s about 80s Oh his job but like mom my
dad never like he kind of never
encouraged that for me like come on you
want to be a welder never broke in order
to go to work he just told me straight
up man you don't want to do this [ __ ]
did it you don't wanna do this [ __ ] and
you know I kind of believe I do it all
but then people that thought were lazy
when I wanted to help him ever again cuz
he never liked my never gonna fix his
car he never invited me like carry the
toolbox hold the flashlight hold the
flashlight not be dog my mom will tell
me well you don't leave I care you want
my help like my mama to push my there
was a moment to push my dad to take me
somewhere
how about your dad do we always have to
go with that how about you well my mom
my mom was you know yeah yeah yella
Pancho no she like blue partner in crime
yes
yeah so you saw I saw I saw another
photo of yours I think about here you
and your wife's anniversary and I'm you
it was a very sad and photo it was you
there and there was a picture of some
other woman women there who had lost on
loved ones you know like and you gotta
stood together on that photo which one
was Hilda photo at our anniversary and
there was a lot of five home girls who
had homies that you grew up with oh no
no no no no those were all made up yeah
no those were okay what I did was I had
a birthday party for Chama Rita I had a
big party and she knew about the party
she means how many to have been together
for 25 years now she's been my
girlfriend since somewhere down the line
I guess what I mean I'll say it you know
with the the attraction the attention
everything I messed up I messed up down
the line she stood with me she stood
with me by I mean by my side to the end
and I'm really you know I'm madly in
love with this woman I mean that's still
when I don't fool around the more I had
my fun okay I finally grew up you fool
around so no I don't know I don't yeah
I'm putting it out there for the world
to hear so can you talk me to fool
around or not you're not like I was like
I I mean you're like me to the hydro
like I could see was gog because a
regular Joe is you easily disappear in
the crowd for you man you would have to
kill somebody after it yeah yeah no I
got nobody you're witnessing ruin my
life it would be hard for you like
kikuchiyo geo sleep with somebody and a
girl have nothing to do to him afterward
so [ __ ] him and leave him you are the
other hand me to the jury
but whatever they want to be there won't
be next to your arm all the time true so
anyway he saw that one detach like a
Lego no so that was her birthday that
was a birthday party that I had for her
I had a stick dancers I had mariachis I
had Guamanian dancers cuz she's from
Guam I did everything had strippers
everything you could imagine was there
rocky but he opened up the show there
was a rocky buddy yeah yeah yeah he
opened up the show for us it was a show
but what she didn't know on that day was
I married her that was the only surprise
so I had a priest come in and the priest
that I had is maverick who was an MMA
fighter if you guys follow up on that
maverick is is somebody real big but he
now he's a priest so I found him on
Facebook we hadn't talked in years and I
said I go is this real because he does
acting as well so I'm like hit me up I
don't have your new number he called me
within I go this this was my way of
thinking I'm a very spiritual person and
I
this was meant to be if this man gets
back to me within five minutes then this
is meant to be he called me in five
minutes again my new number i magmatic
are you a pretty large person that guy I
said I put all my trust on that guy I
lied and I said if you're a priest I go
or is this an acting thing you're doing
and he's like no no brother I'm I'm a
priest now and I'm like okay so you're
not fighting no more he's like I'm not
not at the time I said have you ever
married anybody he's like no I just got
my license and I said would you marry me
and drama Rita and he's like when and
where I'm there
so I'm like wow so we had a quick
conversation I go away let me find out
the day because I don't care I'm there
so he came showed up she thought he was
just one of the guests she didn't even
pay mine why is this guy dressed up in a
priest collar so when we when I started
talking about her on her birthday I was
roasting her talking about how we met
etc etc and I talked about the party
and I go but she doesn't know this day
is that she's getting married and she
broke into tears everybody I think
started crying there and I had it all
picked out now the women that you see
there their husbands having passed
except for one rest in peace but the
rest their husbands are incarcerated
okay and that was when the shootout was
yeah they were in the Shu they were in
the Shu exactly so those those were
heavy heavy dudes but they were present
at my wedding by those pitchers there
and by having the wives there that
señoras being there so that was a heavy
wedding it wasn't your average average
wedding you know I mean I chose them and
your husband's are part of this wedding
as well even though they're incarcerated
so that that's the picture you're
talking about that was actual wedding
she said yes she I made her an offer she
refused I didn't ask her I didn't ask
her I told her I go with you no it was
one of those I didn't get down on a knee
I couldn't say that yeah yeah exactly
so yeah that was the picture using how'd
you guys meet in Terminal Island I was
working on you know white people is a
prison yeah there is a prison right
around there correct correct
well no we didn't meet at the prison
that brothers underground huh cuz never
see that building actually towards the
very end of term Riley oh you know it's
just the very end it ends right there
you've been in there internment I'll
imprison all those things I walked up to
it I do my power walk said last time
when I was working to Terminal Island
and I [ __ ] you not out always walk and
I've hit touch the gate well one time
the thing went off the siren I think I
was a little too close
there-there area so they let the siren
off yeah but now I haven't done federal
typing ti not gonna laugh at this when I
first saw I'm your wife you Instagram
you know like I don't know that I'm when
you guys met or anything so I made up my
own story man yes very she's from Japan
okay no I don't think that I don't know
man somebody thought she was a the woman
that he Miller was there bro and when he
when it when there's um his his his top
team went viral Broglie and she was like
a big fan of like any [ __ ] brother to
America bro bitter citizen like it was
before but I'd say it was all review but
yeah I don't feel like you know did it
happen that way you don't know dawg
alright ya know comedy stuff became my
mom's best friend one day I had brought
her home and I said mom I met this girl
she's real cool she's like are you
serious about her smile she's just cool
you know we hang out and you know blah
blah blah and I go so you want a leader
and she said yeah Chloe they hit it off
so my mom that was a drinking partner my
mom would take her to the bar and they
would hang out and they would do you
know so then my mom was like well are
you you're not serious about it right
and I'm like nah I told you you know
this all good
she goes okay good because there's a lot
of guys asking for her number in the bar
so whoa it was like the needle just went
off the record like wow so I call her up
right so I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you know what you're talking
about I don't know what you're talking
about and then after I go I heard you're
[ __ ] giving your number out what the
[ __ ] in this Annette so she's like I
swear I don't know what you're talking
about I don't you know I love you well
it had never happened my mom just did
that to get us together and that from
there on we gotta gotta forgive then one
day I came home and she had blonde hair
then the next day I came home she had a
tattoo and my mom made her into a chola
know you like build a toilet yeah yes
she did oh yes she did she taught her I
thought oh yeah
well you want to yeah yeah yeah that's
the reason that's the truth get the
toilet breakfast
okay jump little pudding comfy shoes
yeah my mom's doing yeah oh man it's
kind of cool though man yeah
ha ha I didn't know that that's a better
story but know that you're passing is
funny because a lot of people do we did
a show in Oxnard and we came and I
remember all the fellas from Oxford were
coming up shout to the chicas out there
they all came up to me and I [ __ ] you
not
they were they were like hey can we talk
to me to speak English oh I'll just bow
bow and I'm like what do you mean
because you know they go is she from
Japan they had the same concept that you
had that she came from Japan and you
know I'm she's a hit in Japan because
she does have Japanese ancestry and her
great-great grandfather was you know
she's from Guam so they were conquered
by the Japanese as well so she does have
that so when we go to Japan yeah she's
they'll ever out there too
you know when did you first start
tattooing your body yeah it was a lot of
work yeah I have a full body suit I
started at 19 or 20 I was 19 to 20 my
mom had him I wanted him ever since I
was 14 she's a mindful body to know my
mom had a little homemade ones you know
the cross all that dark well I would go
over there turn green after sardaar we
said no and I would tell you that they
remind me of the mold on the tortilla
you know what I mean I like a dream so
yeah hurts what you know let's talk
about the emcee bunch of people don't
know that that I'm old school tattoos or
though like this are old school right
here right there that was done at
somebody's house for no reason because
they were doing a real tattoo somewhere
else
ain't night now do me a tattoo - bro
give me look into it we did it real fast
but um something like indeed oh man you
know they have the oh like a sailor and
like Oh sailor all set to like gum like
bourbon bro his tattoos and but other
little little cell tattoos the other
prisoner too but those two tattoo little
bit bigger like ah I don't know man I
feel like the lines they cut really old
days they were here amid the the needle
of bad remember the needles like I
remember this look Charles giving
tattoos had the big pencil with the
fishing line into the little motor let
it absorb
start our motor done guitar string with
the sleeves were done with guitar string
a sony walkman motor there you go bingo
neato comic guitar solo garages were and
on my porch all of these were done that
route you know with prison tattoo
patterns and that's how these were done
I I haven't gotten a shop tattoo
honestly until I think 2008 2008 was my
first shop so the body was all with a
guitar the majority the majority and
then the fill ins came in the face came
in with the professional out of a shop
San Pedro tattoo my guy out there David
Marcus so yeah a lot of them the
majority my host sleeves were single
needle guitar string in D&E and a sony
walkman motor and one of those what are
those twelve volt batteries are those
big fat batteries yeah yeah it's a -
they're vintage
bro yeah yes about innovation when he
decided to do the face the face was I
ran out of room and honestly it will see
a lot of people like are you sorry I'm
like no cuz it's meaningful you know hey
bro I have question on my forehead I'm
hearing in the mashita you know I have
um well that's right
I have nice to see them see possible
that I have bro and he has a year
without the Hat the shades I have the
mark of watt demo on my face which is
Eagle warrior and that was the name that
I was given so um you know I mean it's
everything's leading for the butterfly
symbolizing my mother which is a new
life buddy boy there's a whole story
with that I don't know if he followed on
that or if you know about that story but
that that story I was you know well
today I'm about a week after my mother
passed away I got a letter from from
this hospital actually in where she
passed Amish memorial and they wanted me
to come to have a barbecue with grieving
family members of lots of level one I
got the letter and I threw it away I
didn't want to go I wasn't ready to
speak to anybody and I felt that I
didn't need it so that same day I'm
cleaning out the garage and this
butterfly a monarch flies it lands on me
lands right on me I thought it was a bee
the way it charged that way yeah it
landed my mom was old school she we
didn't have a washer and dryer so she
would wash her clothes and hang them on
a clothesline so this thing landed on
the clothesline and it's looking at me
one on one and I just got that feeling
so I said mama that's you I think I'll
be okay but just stick around please
that same day she's at work Johnny
Tousley I won't tell her anything about
the story she comes home she tells me
she was outside smoking cigarette at
lunchtime and this butterfly lands on
her pack of cigarettes so I tell her
what kind of butterfly and she was it
was a monarch and I'm like oh okay I
didn't say a word so week goes by I get
another letter from that hospital during
this whole week and I thought I threw it
away so I'm like okay what the hell's up
at this letter so I threw that one away
comes back again with Chama Rita is my
as my witness so now I'm mad at her and
I'm time her why do you keep bringing
this letter I do not want to go meet
with these people at this hospital for
this luncheon I don't need to talk to
anybody I'm dealing with this on my own
so something made me read the bottom and
the bottom said can come and experience
a butterfly release ceremony so that was
the day I was supposed to have my mom
her ashes spread out because she was
cremated she those were her wishes and
she wanted her ashes spread out in Vegas
so I had to reroute our whole trip read
everything because now I have to go
attend a spot and when I went there the
lady who this day I still don't know
what her position was in the hospital
but she was the one that organized this
whole thing and she told me she was like
I'm glad you're here you're here for a
reason like we'll explain to me about
these butterflies and she told me
straight up she goes in a lot of
different beliefs from Native American
to Aztec - everything Hindus they
believed that when we lost a loved one
they come back and they visit us through
a form of a butterfly and she goes on
that's why we're doing this so they had
all these butterflies that were kind of
sedated and you would hold them and some
would drop some would fly away and we
were releasing them and I got to share
stories as well with other people that
lost loved ones which I didn't think I
needed but I guess I did and it was
really touching so from there on I
tattooed that on me and it symbolized my
mother and just recently within the last
year we had we both had an encounter and
I was able to get it on it's on my
Instagram I don't know if you seen that
one didn't know oh you got to see that
one study where it came there was a
butterfly that came in it and it flew
during the rainy season and I'm very
very religious I'm going to the cemetery
that was a comments I made my mother I
have my father my brother I have 13
family members I know all buried in the
same area so my mom was like you just
make sure they all have flowers during
the holidays I don't care you just take
care of all of them so we're actually on
our way to the flower district the
downtown
when this bloody butterfly appeared in
Xiamen Ito had found it in the backyard
of monarch so we thought it was wounded
I didn't know what to do with it we had
it in our hand we brought it in the
house like what do we do it we leave it
in the house we put it in a jar what do
we do with this starts raining we left
headed out to LA to go get our flowers
came back this butterfly was still there
it stood with us for three days so I'm
thinking okay it's going to die on us
well you know what's the deal I felt
that she thought it but neither one of
us said what we felt and the last day
she went to go take care of business run
errands I'm sitting there the butterfly
was still in the back our dogs start
barking like crazy at the back door so I
go over there to see what's going on the
butterfly is right there on the back
step so I looked at it I'm ready to pick
it up I go man the wind must have blown
it I better pick it up it looks like
it's on his last breath the minute I
walked up and I was trying to get my
camera to video because I followed it
every day with the camera it flew away
so all along he was able to fly that
that day I just came back into the
living room I cried like a baby
this was a couple of months ago not even
a year and it was like I needed that to
let and I just wanted to leave while
they left it flew away but not for long
it showed up again maybe like three
months later I have it all documented on
my Instagram that's where I think I
gained a lot of more followers because
life you know I mean I look at me with
the tattoos and everything anyway need
to be speaking like this but you know
people need to realize we need to live
for the ones that we lost I live each
day for my mother my father my brother
all my accomplishments are dedicated to
them and a lot of people don't know how
to cope with death I see my brother died
at 8 years old of an overdose I was
their house mother my brother was 22
years old it was Mother's Day we got the
call and he was right there we stood
with him to the corner you know showed
up and I believe my mom had me there cuz
she could have left me with somebody but
she had me there to prepare me for this
because my dad went nine months later
and I was fortunate to have my mom
another 37 40 years with me so you know
it now I look at it like yes I've lost a
lot but I've gained a lot as well and
I'm able to tell these stories and we
just need to live on and live for those
they're still with their spiritually
there's just not in a physical form my
mom's here with me I mean I always catch
orbs in my videos and
I know who that is you know you've left
a lot of yoke friendly when you were a
kid all guys manually yes yes my best
friends I mean I have a photo album of
Flyers from car washes that I filled up
that it said I was looking at it and I
ran out of room during that 90s era was
the worst time during the drive-bys etc
so I'm an innocent uncle late 80s early
90s is when it really was acted that's
why we say if you survive the 90s man
you know because it was everywhere yeah
you know you're here for a reason
because it was active innocent people
innocent people were getting hit you
know by stray bullets it was bad it's a
bad time it was a bad bad guy Biden is
like in the 90s all over the all over LA
man East LA Boyle Heights
West Side even like Bennett Beach Venice
Beach was a big race war over there like
an eye on who's in Harbor area and I
remember the first time I was I went to
a Raider game load Angela Raiders by the
way there was 1985 right before the
Raiders left it was like my first and
only Ally Raider game and I certainly
got there a big a fight with Harbor area
and somebody else yeah it made the news
out I'm oh my god was on the front page
of the newspaper guy right right now
like but nah it that was in the crazy
part recycle your food poison that same
day damn I always tell the story I
always tell the story Doug we're
watching a [ __ ] game this big ass
cholo from Harbor area jumps on the
field and runs and they can't stop here
my same a little sign this guy it was
like it's like the harbor area totals at
the 50 he's at the 40
that's why me yeah he says attend to
life and I happen to know who you're
talking about sad that dude uh how about
him yeah he was like six to Mexicano Bay
a lot of tattoos just jump on a field
bro and said I could do this and book it
like if you had a dream broke the one
day you wanna play football this is the
only [ __ ] chance yeah yeah no that's
when they stopped serving beer right
after that I got off the beer reporting
oh yeah the last you
here again that was it yeah that was him
glad to make a gel instead of Stadium
yeah it was it was bad yeah doing it I
guess you probably know that guy huh yes
it was like 1987 yeah here tonight
there's like derogate years on derogate
she's gonna be yeah yeah it was very bad
you're a big waiter fab yeah I don't
have a team but I have more Raider gear
than anything but you'll see me all got
it and I've done the wrong I mean a
court according to everybody out there
were - I wore a charger hat with the
Raider jersey
cuz I'm universal you'll see me in
everything you see me the cowboy I don't
you know I mean I'm not a fan but I have
I support all the teams I know I went to
Rams will get mad oh man if you can
stand that like just like a personal
photo with somebody and they tell me bro
put on this hat I put on his hat
I'll [ __ ] you all your [ __ ] 49er fan
now Bhutto you know where they're from
yeah brother everybody knows everybody
they just don't want you huh the guy was
selling souvenirs at Anaheim Stadium and
I'm just didn't watch the game he put on
his Anaheim gear and I him selling
souvenirs I'll call you I'll call I
would call lame fake people actually
play for the others yeah yeah yeah yeah
I went through that I know I saw I know
brother they don't like that boat Oh bro
what are you doing in the church and
Fresno bro have our own church we go out
there and well we're doing over there
was bit throughout week I got your papa
all about praise chapel okay yeah I know
what you're saying now you know what
didn't want that you know I remember
like I did a show and with Gilbert
Escobar way enum enum in the harbor area
bro I did uh I did actually had a
performative funeral at Abu Ali bro
for a guy from that area and man as
we're when you get the Christian on one
side and the family who still drinks bro
same party Catholics and like it's like
you don't know who's better who's the
more berries but then like the group
came up to me Librium Cellini's
please these perfumes they were at the
fiction put the paper fumes and still to
a car it was a cola instead of chorim it
was cook or it was well forget it I
ruined a joke
faculty/staff chaps are karate chefs hai
karate canoe good news Oh school root
brood oh we were just talking about that
the other day we all want boot at one
time hey you haven't good yeah they came
with a kid with a powder we started off
on birth yes we did i Dinklage led their
Old Spice
Old Spice see nothing bruders the ojika
don't get what the green bottle
it came with aftershave and cologne and
something that came with dream powder a
man that wants skin bracer this shiny
club jockey club my dad to [ __ ] with
jacket clothes lucky club yeah they had
a pomade to hogr hi yeah yeah that's
right they did yeah you're hella gonna
be anybody to sponsor you as far as like
clothing lines all in line I've been
generator to have yeah I've been really
really fortunate to have a lot of people
give me different clothing the where you
have your own clothes light like
everything buncha where you know I see
shadow you're sure bro everybody I wish
but but which how many don't tell you
I've never made one cent off of anything
with MC Pancho on it after they've been
giveaways if you see somebody with a hat
or a t-shirt it was given to them you
know I took a lot of merchandise with me
to Japan I can sell it and it'll giving
it out you know so that's mainly what I
do so I'm um your wife she helps you out
with a social media and all that she
does my bookings with the reason for
that is because I'm during the Christmas
time I was doing a lot of fundraisers
you know a lot of you know for for
charities exactly and I booked I thought
I booked Friday Saturday and Sunday but
really what I did was I booked Saturday
saturday Saturday so my Saturday started
off from 7:00 in the morning it went
till 3:00 in the morning
well I had to work the next day at 6:00
in the morning so I told her I go how
can I have booked all of these in a row
I thought I'd spread them out so from
there on I'm like no you do all my
bookings my wife don't let booking too
good I say yet to everything I sorta why
so I don't even know if I'm yeah
and and I honor my word so
gardens I thought about it when I when I
forget to tell her I say it to something
because then she don't know if you can't
do that you gotta be at the audition
oh yeah subbable yeah yeah die
triple-booked that so um sons of anarchy
you were on sons of anarchy you like
acting I like acting I took acting
classes I heard you talking about the
acting classes I took acting classes on
Doheny and I remember on Beverly Hills I
was a one-on-one and I seen acting so I
remember I'd go with my coach and I'd
wait out there and all the thought I saw
the Mexicans I worked in the restaurants
would come out like what are you doing
ready and I'm like well I'm taking
acting classes they you know these are
all the guys I worked in the restaurant
so like all we got an actor we got an
actor and they was able to talk about
the parking attendants guy they wouldn't
charge me there were like all we want to
see you out there you know he's like
you're scaring me you know they they
love me they they took care of me I'm
not lying and they were you know happy
for me at that time I hadn't done
anything
you know but from there on I did Dexter
CSI NCIS Southland I had a movie that
went to big screen with Steven Bauer and
Danny Trejo called Chavez cage' glory I
got to do the red carpet on that so I've
been real fortunate and I did san
andreas grand theft auto I'm one of the
voices on that game was what I would
characterize and the leader of the
Aztecs and I did the car hop and that
was for ps2 that was back in the days so
I heard they brought it back yeah I
don't know if it's the same voices but
the san andreas one I'm the leader of
the Azteca gang yeah well I Isaac he
knows that game so what I love being
tired yeah yeah yeah I started at ps3
mmm so you see them at car shows right
yeah I seen him at the legacy show and
then another and another one in Whittier
oh you hosted a big show in Denver right
but when I do the Denver tattoo
convention every year I did it twice two
years in a row the first in a second
which was last year I do the Laughlin
Viva Tropicana and the Cinco de Mayo and
then I do the Orange County Funk Fest
which is really really big I did that
two years in a row one year they had it
at the Anaheim Convention Center last
year we had it in Costa Mesa Fairgrounds
your show coming up right paid dues or
something no I'm not a hard out when I
don't think I have anything booked who I
I think I'm just coasting because I told
her hosting was
I'm just coasting I call more hosting I
get tiring I mean it's fun and
everything and yeah a childhood is tough
yeah I have a regular job that you know
like I said my longshore on the docks
that I do every day you know aside from
all these other stuff and it's fun but
it's giving me an opportunity for music
acting but um you know I mean it's I'm
not getting it's a funding it's a
funding something that I encourage
people to do but have a job to fall back
on so you read motorcycles no I never
rode that's the the one thing I you know
break a lot of hearts because I met a
lot of friends when I did sons of
anarchy an abandoned on the bike huh
you're on a van no they had me just
posted up like you know understanding
and then I would show up to a lot of
these events for bikers and they'd ask
me hey did you ride down yeah I wrote it
back I wrote in a Cadillac you know I
wrote in the Cadillac hello
and I felt bad like man I'm impersonator
perpetrating that I got things I got in
fact I got the hair down in the chain
and you know but now I'm welcomed by
that community and and I got a lot of
beautiful friends I ride bikes you know
much love to all of them out there
because I made a lot of good people you
know I there's a biker who I thought it
with you but it was in you know not just
tell me you never buy motorcycles it
would like that a mariachi biker or the
photographer he is a photographer me
awhile back
that's another time I saw your photo
okay he shot for me and I don't know I
don't know him either
yeah but I followed him because he ride
a lot of Mosiah yeah I need to be real
cool the photographer he's a
photographer he shot yeah he shot you
along here right with my hair down there
come with whole different person with me
I don't know who the hell you are along
here just disappear like go like them
you look value looking very like iconic
manner you should be like in movies bro
killing vampires bro
yeah go God God thank you thank you
should be that shield bodyguard is
double house we got ID
you said it hey thank you thank you
thank you don't forget to get your Trejo
tacos ha ha ha
that's also as I said you can put a
whole you don't think donor here don't
ask is it so host Costa right here with
fancy poncho room bro when you were
growing up did a yellow truck show what
with dawn ass didn't haven't I don't
think we had the truck with the
doughnuts back then it was that out um
we had what do we Helms bro the hell
that was my mom's date I heard stories
that you guys still haven't been here
from what Boyle height yeah you guys
still have the helmsman we had done I
lied you dude Oh white man you should
have a Helms truck you should show up to
the hood in the projects 1982 1984
bust up a little ways over river and
then he'll Chuck they open a truck and
they open the bottom tray and they'll be
nothing but glazed doughnuts I heard
stories of that we didn't have it in the
harbor area I heard him the Fuller Brush
man has old brushes and combs that was
another one go yeah look we're going old
school look at the roller brush man who
go that Fuller Brush and in and of
course the the was at the dairy guy the
yeah yeah but no we didn't know we
didn't have us doughnuts pico de gallo
man Roy Helms cover Syria okay yeah me
we do we talk terrible Dolan bro
bomb Donna's room how much were they
back then there's quarter probably yeah
there were five cents five finger
discount bro oh yes I went up I remember
um I was invited to a 4th of July party
in San Pedro it was it was at a place in
San Pedro where I think it's like an
empty lot the everybody has a has has
unfolded July parties there and it was
not really a park I just know we parked
up to here oh and we walked down and it
was like open season bro on picnic areas
there oh wow it was like uh it was not
even a part it was like a lot it was all
wooden right it was all dirt and
everybody was partying okay man these
pools busted out illegal fireworks
at this place the one that showed up in
the sky and explode can mortars what
this who had judge dude they blew up a
pathway to the sky so everyone running
for cover dogs Wow I was like [ __ ]
Armageddon dog there was flames falling
off Patricia who's gonna run away with a
water dog oh compatible yeah so um so
what do you do most of the day man
besides we no no work people were more
like you actually work at yeah I work or
it seems like from the photos that
you're just like it seems like you just
hanging out all day at events and [ __ ]
you know you know III know show me I'll
be people ages I do the games in the
[ __ ] longshoremen yeah yeah where you
learn to work towards a good hold no no
no IRA my money now I earn my money I
use the break room you know somebody
does the push because she just had come
on like you know do some tonight oh my
god I gotta go to work tomorrow like
really so she pushes me I don't know
where she gets the energy but she pushes
me to these things but I mean I work
associate little you're the man party I
don't know what thing is on the port no
need you to conclude oh thank you I'll
tell Elena what the [ __ ] he didn't prep
rebar yeah we travel where ain't no way
I'm gonna work in the morning you're
chasing huh it's actual construction
head yeah Lina yeah don't end there's
any breakfast I know you're totally sick
yeah no I mean I usually like id's no I
don't have kids of Germany Testarossa
like I got close to to the grandkids you
know I mean but no I don't I don't have
any that I know about but a lot of them
have been coming forward on
thanks for social media that oh that's a
problem I deal with your mean sure he's
Dan yeah but these are people that it
can't be so I kind of thought about what
that could be maybe my brother maybe
that was you know what I mean I don't
know no no it's not me
you know I was still a virgin at that
time away so no yeah I can't even
believe I put that out there yeah that's
for reals yeah seriously you're my
father yeah this match Inc yeah I'm a
pimp 11 the guy's 40 years old but I'm
his dad yeah I want to hang yeah daddy
buy me a steak I like that word now well
you would you don't like a restaurant
you never be known instagramming Sally
they made me wait all day and I don't
get paid for that I heard now yeah I
guess you can but I mean we we put the
ones out there that show us love the
treat is good and you know I like fine
eating you know cuz I didn't have that
growing up
hell no no no I'm not something I do
like now when you have a little bit
money eating dirty yeah yeah I will do
he's good right now he will create what
here good where he goes Carlton but
sometimes you know you get to eat
something you don't normally eat like
snails
hell yeah of Cour go oh I did that in
Japan yeah that one bro uh-huh yeah I
always thought it's called global the
snow for the garden bro I was turned off
they what I always liked because I don't
want to eat like mom I don't wanna cook
you a salt and I out here like stupid I
chefs on wheel oh my god with the warran
just like to take that one day though
yeah
beat these [ __ ] P they'll be yeah man
LS how do you got my video yeah I want
to have watch our follow MC punch on
instagram you could watch from the
beginning to the end of our folder man
it's hilarious cuz I'm pleased is funny
my like a ticker six months ago you
started off at almost a Lutie waiting I
started out good thank you so much so
many partial has a big old plate full of
fried mac and cheese with lobster and
everybody is like what happened yeah
yeah yeah I couldn't see people out
there having a good time man you seem to
enjoy it
enjoy life now I live it to the fullest
you know I mean I'm not people always
ask me how did I make a change I'm not a
changed person it's just thanks to
social media my stories I get to show
you there's another side of me
we don't gangbang Elijah thirteen years
old that's a photo you were [ __ ] 13
then I started on your four team of
almost twenty bro yeah I got shattered
iron knuckles out who beat you up bad
boy give me that man yeah was i I grew
up fast I grew up really really fast and
fascinated by fools [ __ ] with Python
you really total like totally fascinated
you I mean I grew up around it my
brother you know my dad was an original
pachuco my dad was on the pachuco days
get along here too like you my dad grew
his hair for Amanda yeah so he did that
but when de amanda is a spiritual thing
where you make a promise and you grow
your hair for a reason and then he took
it to Mexico and left it there and it
made this promise you know where you are
you bury it yes yes you get yes see
there's an old school yeah yeah because
that's back in the day like because the
particles were like the ones that came
in from World War two didn't really have
anywhere to go could get jobs and
there's the one that started [ __ ]
fighting with the Navy living jenavian
they were actually ex [ __ ] military
to subscribe clicking on them they did
their close up because they were all
about style military style and object
tree stuff the military press right yeah
back then um with an article they made
zoot suit resume a zoot suit outlaw oh
yeah yeah it's all against it yeah they
would rip up
yeah it would rip them up act in and rip
them right off is basically just [ __ ]
with them yeah there we a cultural the
town exactly yeah
because that's way before that the
Pendleton days and all the dogs that
says that was for originally you have a
chook oh then you had cholo and then it
just went into you know whatto and
exactly you know yeah who are the ones
that had the pen all the way to the top
yeah they're called rape so there is a
stock coochie drapes I remember had a
joke about that man and we're totally
very tough long as [ __ ] pants hey
that's why when you die but you put the
pencil over your head
and you want to see you open the zipper
yeah they're yeah they're high-waisted
so you're there each other which are my
uncle and TJ one of the wanna cholos
broke and it was the hardest [ __ ] yeah
so I could do it you know Tijuana cholo
in the alley told her that she won a
total uses Haynes bro so [ __ ] you by the
collar going loose and that was
something because we used to when I
overheard with JC Penney's Stanford or
town craft before those were mandatory
those were men before pro club and all
that came out and those were mandatory
nobody had anything I wonder right yeah
but um except I yeah they had to be yeah
that's part of the uniform you know I
mean you had you could leave the house
you had to be pressed you get a creases
I still work Reese's Cup my pants and I
saw the color button up but you can't
cut dope with that [ __ ] yeah I love you
don't say private more like because if
you're like if you follow the dirty ass
Pig you know there's some of your dirty
ass thing you know there's nobody
telling the kid April generational
though like the book of you know doc
what I do good match like right now a
day like ah and I look to cinemas how
the need is personal world you know but
I have like myself a babe others clothes
on the floor right now they need to be
picked up that what do you do you're
neat I have clothes everywhere I read
another room for it she'll tell you have
like a 100 hats in the living room okay
so glass when I do invite you guys over
I'll make sure I clean the house real I
want to tell you one why I wanted to do
the effort we love talking to Lisa on
the manager about interviewing you I
wanted to go to your house because you
did I interview in your house with a
young a young homie and I think I know
that that kid is it was at your house
that we showed all the the mural long
you all you have a room full of art like
prison art of cooking a mass collection
um let's talk about the Teen Angels and
telling everybody what teenage your
magazine because I always tell people
that was our facebook before Facebook oh
yeah teenager played a big role now I
first appeared a teenager in 1982 that
was when teenager the original the
father put a favorite photo that we'll
post it off okay okay okay 1982 was the
first time
I remember I saved up money gave it to
my mom used to recycle bottles back then
and I told her get me a money order I
need five dollars I gotta send this
picture in and I'll never forget it was
one of my Heights in the high school
junior high pictures I was in seventh
grade I got a smile from here to here
and I'm next to these guys all hardcore
that were in prison with big overall
shots and I'm smiling from ear to ear in
the middle that was something you know
to say look I'm a teenager that was
something so we developed a you know it
was something that yeah Bob years old
and and me and this man developed a
friendship so I would send him Christmas
cards he would send them back to me he
was the man that founded teenager the
artist of the legend the light is right
the white yes you who you were article
about him he's a little story a little
story on that yeah I was so lame um we
just do my stealing Joe last name was
haulin his son
smiley took over he had a son by also
that got into rapping so he had teen
angel records you had a teen angel of
the magazine which the son took over and
we just knew everybody just knew him as
teen angel that was that period you know
a real private man but talented talented
artists and opened up the doors for a
lot of us from Northern California
Southern California actually everywhere
out-of-state whom X you know just by
having your picture in there with
something like you made what made him
create the magazine he was an artist for
lowrider magazine nowadays if you look
in the original first lowriders with
sunny Madrid that first came out he had
a section in there and it was teen
angels art then when someone else took
over and bought it he went his own way
and he started teen angel magazine and
Tina's you marry the man was they still
a regular regular magazine but never a
real baggage it's a paperback convential
Polaroids cut and pasted photos of
people there a lot of press door
everybody yes yes dedication metal arms
and I remember me and my mom would go on
the bus to downtown LA Broadway and
those little green houses to sell all
the magazines right there we go up and
down I wish I have one and get I'll give
you one I have I have a big collection
and I have a couple of doubles Vakula
thank you I remember like this is how
you know that out there was one teen
angel magazine that's one pilot when I
owned you open up in the middle and you
know I'm remember Michael Jackson
Thriller album how he's laying and
laying at our suit what is teen angel
he's there in a in a thong bro he's very
like in a bikini like in a bathing suit
look and it Michael Jackson laying there
looking like a cholo bro uh-huh
while drew Michael Jackson and another
drew Michael Jackson like a cholo
chilean bro with no t-shirt on it was
like the Thriller one just one I got a
look too bad I'm sorry a lot of people
like people from all over label submit
photos to a teen in Georgia hardcore
cholos that's how he got in there right
cuz anybody from the outside they would
send it to their family than the family
and they would it well back then to the
prison system was different so he had an
understanding with them and it was like
you send it in with ten stamps you know
so postal stamps it was a public there's
no photo they made it from from our
neighborhood they made it inside of the
teen angel activity as you see right
there that's a la submitted art from
somebody that is old school right there
yeah Wow
this is um what some of the saw that
they would put up a lot of it was
original street art that's why I kind of
cultivated that style right yes yes he's
ended up dying like right there what
Sammartino or something yeah well that's
where he was at in that in the IE and so
what had happened was his son he gave
his son one of them by also the record
you run teenager records the other one
you run the magazine your income will
keep coming from there so somewhere down
the point they couldn't they could get
any artwork
nobody was submitting artwork the
culture was kind of dying out and I've
seen that they made a comment is still
around so I have in history I do have
the biggest art collection I mean you've
seen I you know from the videos I do
have the biggest prison art collection
period so I started sending artwork to
them and let me backtrack back when I
started doing rapping I had sent teenage
with a man my underground tapes so
little did I know that his sons had you
know listen to my music growing up there
were little at the time so when I
started submitting this artwork they put
two and two together wait a minute you
the guy that sent my dad to tapes I'm
like yeah yeah I did back in the days
and I'm like aw man but we're going to
use your artwork so I kept teenager
alive and I'm glad I could put this
story out there because I was never
credited for it nor cha Morita we kept
teenagers your life for probably about
another 20 30 issues if you look at
those
use the new one the Calais back the ones
that came out when the Sun was running a
from front to back is all my artwork
that I personally own then somewhere
down the line someone else took over
we never got created and now somebody
else is running it out of the San Diego
area but like I said we never got credit
for keeping that alive and all the
artworks submitted but probably 20
issues is mine and not to mention when I
went to Japan they were so fascinated
with teenager they wanted to start
teenage of Japan and they had asked me
if I could contract a deal so I talked
to the son and I told him I said they
want a contract a deal in Japan and he
goes hey Pancho you know you don't even
have to ask me that's another country
they could do it yes or no I don't know
they want to do it the proper way they
want a contract and they have a generous
contribution that I have here to give
you so are you with it
the guy came flying down from San
Bernardino in ten minutes and he's like
where do I sign so I gave him a check
and we started that I had no time to run
teen angel magazine because I was
touring I'm still doing music and I was
doing all my other stuff so um Chama
Rita I bought her a camera when I said
here you're going to be the editor for
teenagers Japan so what she did was
followed me to car shows concerts etc
where I went took pictures and submitted
them and they did two issues of
teenagers Japan with her as the editor
and the publisher although that was her
position and then then the tsunami came
and it just became an Internet magazine
once the tsunami hit because it was
everything it just changed everything
their gala was because I know that the
magazine came back after it was gone for
a long time from the 90s and to
thousands of mad droughts and now you're
out there exact surgeons now yeah now
they have what they call cholo hipsters
you know yeah yeah now yes that
collection and people want it all there
I I'm Angela well when I did the music I
left that out too I was the Sun had was
so happy that I contributed so much
artwork so he gave me a lot of artwork I
bought a lot of artwork that his father
did I have a big collection of teenage
artwork but he goes let's do something
in history that nobody has I go ass at
he goes let's give you your own teenager
issue so I go how's that he goes it'll
be all your artwork well but it'll be
teenager presents MC Poncho's picks and
we'll release that with your CD and
that's what put me back in the game so
he's responsible as well so I do have
something I have a map my own teen angel
issue which tells a story of my father
my brother meet
I mean up and all my artwork and you
know I mean it's part of history and
that that one goes for I think six
hundred dollars on eBay which that ass
people are selling which I don't even
know I seen though this is a grip yeah
yeah they're good magazines man I
remember like I just aged like it's
opening up and you can spend all day
watching I'm just it's been all day on
Instagram oh [ __ ] yeah it'll be like no
show like old school black gangs bro
just chilling right there you know I
think I'm for Trey crimp used to be oh
yeah with a train a train right right I
belong here yeah yeah Menlo yeah and I'm
hard peace bro well somebody will just
do a little draw and then they'll be
like a dedication to my homie who just
passed away and then they lived on bro
people to read them all [ __ ] and
that's the whole thing it's said people
that document like the underground of
the underworld this part of [ __ ]
America that's I think a lot of really
and at large sometimes sometimes you
know when a cop where to find somebody
who just pick up a teenage old guys but
it's funny because they did you use here
yeah many people did I was going to hit
the news I remember the news did a big
we're like you know what happened
oh no no cuz in that way they can like
to tie you to crime and homies and
affiliates and all that [ __ ] yeah if the
detectives are hip enough to [ __ ] with
that man oh yeah cuz why here this this
right here this owner I just showed you
has the whole of the whole gang here bro
whole lineup and I can say we're the
retro people right now that's one thing
they had a reunion last week anyway they
you so happy and all that [ __ ] you know
from my yeah some people don't realize
and they put themselves out there too
much yeah same things that they
shouldn't say you know and they put
themselves out there and they're setting
themselves up yeah my turn off your
location I love you what you wanna go
eat with empty monitor you know where
you don't have people show up is Oh
empty parts I knew you were here man but
started eating yes we heard it yes and
thank you for the ones that do that to
the rock from Florencia that came from
LA live all the way to seventh Street
where we were posted up Scooby much love
thank you this that's not Killian that
is no that is the whole reward of PTSD
kasha when somebody comes up and when
they'll tell me like you know I know you
were you know that that's the whole
reward really I wish people more people
would approach me I know I got this
Moscow Dallas look but Plymouth you know
come up to me and and that's the whole
thank you you know for acknowledging me
and and you know wanting to come up and
shake my okay merely to meet you that's
a Halloween somebody actually did that I
heard what I love they put a mustache in
yeah yeah a co-worker did yeah trying to
get more hours yes duty fingernails oh
my god that's funny man so you will have
a lot of clothes what's your favorite
shirt to wear because you always post-op
that that famous potato chip it would
you go by Pendleton but deliver green
okay let's repeal all Greenspan's
everything and Josh they've showed me
nothing but love my mom first took me in
there you know so everything always ties
is always a mom story with that she took
me into Greenspan's back in the day the
grandpa was old man yeah yeah yeah he
would always give us the whole history
on it how many penalties you old every
bunch of I stopped counting at a hundred
and so dance okay your gg-go you beat
you I stopped counting there so do okay
so how many you have f12 yeah but their
song MC puncher there so this one mom
some penalty into the heart of farther
collectible right right right see the
only thing that sucks about those is
they're like even like the extra large
were built when people were tiny
there's no way they make good on Vinny
because he finds them all the time I'm
fitted they're a fan who said I put an
extra large Pendleton to be over my
buddy for people not for the new
American no now they came out with the
long and yeah finally did a 3 X 4 X back
then Dana had those I don't know what to
a style blog bro I don't know I'm with
it hell yeah because we have a couple of
Toledo 200s right now bro the way nein
there's nothing a normal school you know
my I think the picture you're talking
about with me with the Pendleton was the
story that I had told I wanted back then
everybody had cascade and cascade was
was a lower grade of a penalty and
because that's our record what Charlie
Brown's to what cascade made something
similar I know you talked about the
Charlie Brown but they made something
similar that looked like a penalty and
it was a wool shirt that itch the hell
are you you get a rash but they were
affordable so everybody in school nobody
had a real pen
can I remember I told my mom I wanna
Cascade and she was so you really want
to be a cholo you want to do this which
is where you're gonna do it the real way
come on I'm gonna go take you and buy
you a penalty that's not a Pendleton so
she took me I remember we went in there
we're looking at them and she goes pick
what you want we'll put it on layaway
and I'll get out for you for Christmas
if you get all bees if you get good
grades cease no actually she asked for
seeds and ease and I was like okay all
right we got a deal so we made a deal I
went in and I remember I asked the guy
that worked there I said how much are
these and I'll never forget it was a
white dude and he told me straight up he
goes too much for your blood and I
didn't know what that meant I told my
mom I go this guy came and he told me
that these were too much for my blood
what does that mean
and she goes quiet [ __ ] that
[ __ ] go pick pick pick I will
miss you want take every so I think I
picked three or four penalties out and
she's like she paid cash right there on
the spot
well that was a whole month's check for
Social Security that was what if the
laughs doesn't pay the bills and
everything
I remember we ate out of a can that
whole month but she got me those and she
goes don't let me down you little
[ __ ] you better get those grades
okay and I did tonight inhale big and I
did I got those grades for her and that
was a story with my Pendelton so she
bought me the real deal you know I mean
it I'll have a good camera to see what
it'd be like oh let me huh this is how
we do it see that money you know she
told me straight up she was like you
know I like her I like her a lot but my
job really I'm not sure that much Akana
it also swayed her into you know she
changed her closer I can buy a generator
you know cause Tom Beneatha had that
long hair past her but you know I mean
you could put a lei around her if you
know she had that Island look you know
that I really liked I got me an island
girl like that chick on the water was
that one that's on the water coolers or
the or the dole what is that the
pineapple juice yeah she had that look
and I was like what did you do to her
you died in her blind and no showroom I
lived to look at Hawaiian card oh yeah
my mom in twenty-something years and you
know I mean hominid thigh learned a lot
from us but I always say there's one
thing that she couldn't learn from us
that she was born with and that's hard
you know I mean I don't encourage
fighting or anything like that violence
but she she could get him up you know I
mean yeah she's she's she backs her [ __ ]
up and and I guess that's why we're that
couple
that Bonnie and Clyde and you know we
don't go robbing banks to do anything I
exactly towards old as that couple you
know and and it's real you know I mean
and I'm glad she stood by my side and
pushes me to do what I do you know my
wife pushing here a lot too man let it
be get pushed like I need to be told two
times what am i doing like I just get so
impatient sometimes like you happened to
you like all right already a i've been
impatient and i've wanted to hang this
up a few times retire and just exit this
business because you meet a lot of fake
people and I'm sure you know people [ __ ]
okay the majority you don't meet too
many real people it's sad it really is
and it discourages you when you really
see how a person is deep down oh yeah
that's why I say with social media I get
to show people so I'm always stereotyped
and people think I'm this certain way
that I could show off or floss or do
this and I like to show you know I work
for this this is how I got this and you
don't know my life we don't know I lost
a lot to gain what I have you know so
social media don't long shoreman one of
the things you said on your when I when
I found out you were long shoreman I
didn't know your longshoreman I thought
he would just guy with a lot of jewelry
ice baller or saying stereotype yeah he
might I said somebody who retired from
the game a long time ago and I was doing
good but you said now you say in that
one video that no man I work my
longshoreman you know I've worked real
hard for everything I got every little
piece of jewelry I had to put in money
put in time work on that crane right and
I still lay away you know I mean there's
there something I was a window shopper
we were window shopping we used to go to
to a lay down town take the bus go to
Clifton's cafeteria back in the day list
yeah yeah she I get emotional chime so
I'll tell you and I get emotional in
there it's like that's what my mom will
take me you know what I mean and it's
it's weird like we spent so much time in
downtown LA that was a getaway jump on
the bus we take the 446 rtd from South
Bay little all the way to to Union
Station Wow and that was our thing we
know that schedule she'd have a car we
don't have a car that no I mean so my
life like I said growing up I mean it
wasn't tough but she didn't make it
tough
she made it fun it was fun you know I
mean now I look at him like man we
didn't have this we didn't have that but
she had her way of going around it or
saying we don't like it you know it's
bad for you that way sorry bad for you
exactly exactly tenly for us me the
whole evil why people per our blood well
for Allah
oh podcast gemiini shows coming up or if
you want to promote your Instagram just
I mean Google me or MC poncho number two
on their cha Morita does all the videos
on there and we you know this is the
first podcast I've done and come back
again do it again
Thank You special podcast hahaha thank
you though thank you who else he
postulates people thing about to not to
be mistaken with MC Boulevard thank you
you know that guy MC bolivars I do I
love an American meat documentary okay
oh yeah yeah he was a bookie he was
cooking you [ __ ] the MC MC Bulevar
with a poncho in another head or a
repair oh oh yeah what's up fool oh yeah
big plan for Labor Day you do they know
why don't you do something want to have
a steak hell yeah I'll be here bro oh
you're vegan yeah I'll just have some
best being in tacos in the world over
who is a chili dragon white foo Jack
what yeah okay we'll do some of those
hell yeah bro you know what I like
Chinese food bro a little one [ __ ] in
Chinatown I should about right there
yeah yeah you haven't seen the video
yeah yeah a walk on news well [ __ ] to
borrow my wife I want after going this
is over the kid cuz I still live right
there and I'd you know they do name
Delroy and need to let me to love the
duck but I took my wife hot woo we like
how whoo but we should go there one car
late at night you know the the Chinese
maitre d together greets you yeah [ __ ]
cool guy man he does everybody's there
they don't even try do I write funny as
hell you know yeah that's responder
that's a better seen come here ya know
we yeah I mean one of the few places
where you can see though the real faces
of a lay you know you see hipsters there
yeah I read you see you see book a
shitload of mariachis there yeah a
shitload of cops you see people just a
jail well $40 to eat yeah they go
straight to one [ __ ] yeah
and they love that place you know I know
it's good bro when you go to a bathroom
just a mop
well thank you very much MC punctuate
you were dragged over here to honor you
thank you thank you Tom Aretha man you
got a very lovely couple thank you
you're like Bonnie and Clyde Thank You
Felipe that means so much you know just
by you saying you follow me man thank
you oh yeah Brian I know that he started
explaining well you know who I am and I
know who you are damn it
[ __ ] I know you are you thank you I hope
it Boyle Heights bro pickle gardens and
a gated community the windows were gated
the back door was heated
what are so cool Lisa yes you're eager
ACOD shimonita who do you want to
salespeople or what you're more than
welcome to have a new man of spencey
bunch of love dancing so so we still
either we turn a dance with him I just
enjoy life but this weekend we're gonna
be at people want to I'll probably be at
the brac Tavern that's the spot we've
been hanging out right there on seventh
Street it used to be the old Clifton's
remember there was - cliff - yeah so the
brac is the old Clifton's I've been
hanging out right it's Vince M Street
that's a oh that's why that is the old
Clifton man yeah and what do I like
about your videos also is that when you
show to a place like just a downtown LA
you give a little story how it used to
be when you put it right - right
- is change a lot of people when I tell
them to go you're hanging out in LA I
mean you remember there was a time once
it got dark we had to bounce
how are you had a business down did not
want to be at the Tower Theater in the
arcade long 18 three guys they got me a
few times they hit me oh yeah I should
get a gangster's 18 street they would
hang out at that arcade right there yeah
I remember quarter tired but it would be
that quarter and I got here I remember
get out of yeah those were damn times
change was so poor jingle shows yeah
this Saturday August 19th in Pomona at
the backdoor cocktail on Superfly mm
empty Pancho appeared to Brer Improv in
Brea California in next week August 24th
to a twenty sevens and I would love to
invite you and your wife for the
Saturday night show we would that is our
anniversary and we will be there are you
sure so what I will describe you in the
birds no I
that's an honor we would let us know
you guys will set it up don't stand in
line just call me son okay thank you
guys all right oh yeah that's proper
Matt cake you know where we'll be August
24th on our anniversary
really I love to have a guy there right
thank you very much
what's our food park elegiggle yeah man
check out the mmm podcast and we're back
at Romano the 23rd epoxy poncho or
Instagram thank you both
everyone so two on the champ cab thank
everybody up there Thank You Johnny
brother